hey this is Sarah with registered nurse
Orion column in today I am making a
video on how to insert a Foley catheter
on a female patient in the previous
video I showed you how to open up your
foley kid and I educated you on what was
actually in the kid and how to inflate
the balloon and mess with the betadine
and everything like that so if you need
to get familiar with that you'll want to
check out that video before actually
watching this video so in this video I'm
going to actually show you how to insert
a Foley catheter from beginning to end
right here we have miss Smith she is our
mannequin patient today and you'll want
to before you even insert the Foley
catheter you want to discuss it with
your patient to make sure that it is
something that they want you'll want to
discuss on how it's inserted what
position they'll be in that they'll be
exposed momentarily in their private
region and the risk of a Foley catheter
insertion so always let them be aware
because believe it or not a lot of
patients don't know what a Foley
catheter is or where it's actually
inserted so you always want electro
patient there about that next you'll
want to address their allergies because
in the kit there is betadine a lot of
patients are allergic to betadine so
you'll need to get another prep agent or
if they're allergic to latex this kid
that I have it does contain some latex
so we want to make sure your patient is
allergic to latex and if they are what
type of reaction is a severe so water is
really not a reaction they just consider
it a reaction so you'll want to look at
that as well so first thing we'll do and
after we've educated our patient we will
get our Foley kit and do hand hygiene
after that and you'll want to get your
patient in position it's really a good
idea to have another person in the room
to help you and just because
nature of the procedure you're going to
be in a patient's private area you want
another person with you so we can get a
nursing assistant or another fellow
nurse to help you out so keep your
patient in position for females I like
to get them in this position put the
legs up and try to preserve modesty as
much as you can a lot of people or
modest this is sort of an embarrassing
position to be in so try to make them
feel as comfortable as possible I had
one patient tell me that a Foley
catheter insertion is just as bad as a
pap smear so please try to make them
feel comfortable so um what I'm going to
do is I'm actually going to pull the
towel back and let your Maj know
everything that you're doing I'm going
to pull the towel back and expose the
the labia and the vaginal area I'm on a
female patient you have to inflate ium
and you have the urethra which is the
entrance to the bladder and then below
that is another entry and that's the
Badger area and then the bottom is the
anus so that's how you have that on a
female next you'll want to go to your
kit and your kit comes in a plastic bag
be sure you grab the crack get some kids
in the clean hold or just the Foley bag
and other kids are just the prep supply
so you'll want to if you're inserting a
brand new kit that you have the Foley
bag and the prep supply this one has
that so you will open up your kit they
just go back like this I like to use
this plastic part as my trash bag um
because it's just easier because I'm
going to have cotton balls to throw away
things that throw away so it's easier
just to access that and probably
and reach for a trash can or throw to
the patient's bed so you can pull your
kid out it will comes right with this
drape and I'm it's sterile on the inside
I just pull it back and I like to set my
bag in between the patient right there
so I can just drop it in okay
the kid you will pull back you have two
inches around the edge of your sterile
field to pull back and to expose the kit
so we will do so everything in the kit
is sterile okay so you'll want to be
careful when accessing it you don't want
to contaminate it usually how your kit
is laid out its laid out how you will
use it the first thing I'm going to use
is a dray I'll take my drink remember
you have two inches to grab without
contaminating this and this strength
will be used to put around our patient I
will have two inches so I'm still
sterile and we'll just put that around
the vaginal area down here just to
protect any area sometime you have to
mess with it's a little bit complicated
likes to crinkle up then we will slay
like that um next you have your sterile
gloves and with your sterile gloves you
can put those on because once you put
your sterile gloves on you can get in
the kit and mess with everything because
you will be sterile and I have a video
on how to put on sterile gloves if you
don't know how to fit on sterile gloves
there's a certain
me too doing that so you want to watch
that video
adjust your boils once you get them on
sometimes they like to stick their in my
trash can and this is another drain I am
use that sometimes sometimes I don't
want really depends just easily like
that they own be careful when you light
them because you don't want to
contaminate your blood so just lay it
down just like that and next what we're
going to do we're going to get our
betadine and have your tweezers so get
your betadine there's a little tear
opening on it sometimes it's a little
complicated right there's a little
slight you're going to just tear it open
and you're going to drizzle it onto the
cotton bolls you have six cotton balls
so just drizzle it like so and Miss
Smith is not allergic to betadine so
that is why I'm using betadine then just
put that in your trash can and like to
let that sit and get all getting betta
have a $2.00 on it and next you will
have your flush not your flush I'm sorry
your sterile water to inject into the
bulb of the Foley because you always
want to make sure that your Foley bulb
works and one time I was inserting a
Foley catheter and the bowl did not work
so I had to get
Kathir kit so believe it or not the holy
bulbs sometimes are and then this right
here is your lubricant that you watch
you lubricate the catheter and this is
if you had to collect any urine because
a doctor wanted a specimen so next what
I'm going to do is I'm going to check my
Foley catheter bulb to do that I'm going
to get my catheter this thing is in a
little protectant this is your Katherine
this is actually what's going to go
inside of a new read run you will want
to connect this take this part off and
you will connect this into this port
right here there's two ports this port
right here is where you access for a
specimen this is where you're going to
inflate a lot of times it says inflate
10 cc's so you're just going to connect
to that and watch this bulb make sure in
place see how that plant sling and
insert all the sterile water just look
at your bulb make sure that it doesn't
leak it's good and make sure it deflates
- I usually look at it for about fifteen
to thirty seconds and just let go of the
plunger on the syringe and saving at the
deflates which it does works great I
like to keep just protectant on it until
right before I insert because this thing
likes to move and it can just go off the
sterile field and then that's an extra
barrier to prevent it from getting
tamponade so I'll just set that aside
and next what you can do is get your
lubricant comes in a little prefilled
syringe and sometimes it comes in this
little thing that you just tear off and
you just squirt out this one has a
syringe I like to just squirt it in my
tray like that and set we have our
betadine with our under cotton balls and
we have our lubricant and then we have
our Foley catheter I notice I kept the
syringe connected to the Foley catheter
so when I ever actually inserted I don't
have to move and fiddle with this and
try to get it reconnected it just makes
it a lot easier to keep it connected so
once you are inside the bladder and you
get your yard and returned and you
inflate the bulb you don't have to try
to find your syringe okay so now what
we're going to do is we are going to
clean the labia now when you do this
you'll want to use your non-dominant
hand to spread the labia apart so you
can clean with the betadine because once
that hand touches the patient it's non
sterile so you can all bring the hand
back to your kit you're going to have to
work with your dominating so it's very
important whenever you're positioning
positioning yourself on the bed that you
position yourself so you can work more
with your dominant hand so first what
we're going to do we're going to go to
our patient and we're going to spread
out the labia and just warn your patient
that it will be cold and then you're
just cleaning the area with some
betadine you're going to go you're going
to start and go from top to bottom so
you're just going to slide that like so
don't cotton ball get another one going
to do the other side slide through there
really making sure you get the area
clean very well and go down the middle
just keep doing it until you run out of
your cotton balls just following the
same pattern
it's just prevents any chances of the
patient getting a UTI or any
contamination from the normal flora
that's in the vaginal area then you're
done with your tweezers so just put that
in your bag next you'll want to get your
Foley catheter very careful when you
take this out because it likes to move
okay you're going to take this end of
this catheter and you're going to really
lubricate it up really dip it in there
get it nice and lubricated then you're
going to bring it over here to the
motion and you're going to find where
the urethra is on many female patients
this is a little complicated it's a
little hard you really got to get down
there you got to look because sometimes
the urethra gets displaced up inside the
labia it's very hard to see sometimes
you insert it in the vagina so it takes
some practice okay so we have this as
the mannequin so it's very easy to see
you're going to insert inside the hole
okay and while you're doing this you're
going to be looking right in that - okay
because once you hit that - you're going
to see some yellow urine and typically
you would start right now seeing some
yellow urine peeling this chamber right
here the tube and whenever I see that I
like to advance a couple more inches
just to make sure it's in the bladder
because you don't want the bulb to fill
up in between the bladder and the
urethra you want to make sure that bulb
fills up in the
because that would cause the patient a
lot of pain so we have yellow urine
we're going to insert just a couple more
inches and then we're going to light our
bulb is inflated then going to just undo
that for that Irishman and just hug it
out
and it'll stay rot in place so you have
our Foley catheter inserted and you'll
want to get one of the secure things
that secure to the thigh and we'll stay
right there on the patient and you'll
take your Foley catheter and you will
connect this down to the bed because
this is where all the urine will collect
in this chamber right here and if you
had to collect a specimen you could have
your syringe and you can connect to this
part right here and suck out any urine
and click that and after you do that
just connect it to the bed and get your
patient all disconnected here and
covered up and reposition them and make
them feel a lot more comfortable and ask
the patient if there's any pain how does
it feel to her and those things help you
know if it's okay take your gloves off
course and then do hand hygiene so
that's how you insert the Foley catheter
and it's a very simple procedure it does
take practice so doing it over and over
again will help you and if your nursing
school using the mannequin in class is
very helpful and you get a lot of skills
with this you get your sterile loving
down you get your sterile technique how
to insert a Foley catheter on a patient
you wonder what a different skill so I
think
by a nursing school they have us do a
lot so if you like this video please
share it with your friends if you need
to watch a video on how to put on
sterile gloves or you need more
explanation on the foley kit please
check out those other videos and thank
you so much for watching